hey
hi everybody
hi everybody
if you can hear us those online can you
raise your hands
we'll wait
two more minutes
the event is both typical and virtual
so we are only
a eight person sitting at the impact
tech at the moment
with
success
and and let's wait until the past five
past five percent
[Music]
oh
[Music]
team
[Music]
okay i'm good
okay
hello everybody both virtually and
physically
and we haven't had the
physical events in some time
the last one we tried
failed a bit
and because it was
any more
red
area you called
so this is this is
this is the
let's say the first after recovery event
with a significant physical presence
and
we're here at impact tech at the
impacted office in limassol
in cyprus for those
that are abroad
and
the agenda for today i will i will
spend one two minutes to present pi dida
and by data cyprus and then georgina
will talk to us about
uh
we will say some words about impact tech
and automl
so
i'm starting
[Music]
can you see the screen
okay
it should be fine okay
so
um
for those who are not aware of the
meetup it's um
it's a
global
meetup which can be described as a forum
where
the global community let's say of
users and developers of tools related to
the data analysis can come together
in
in meetups or experiences
on a
different kind of frequencies there are
monthly meetups all over the globe
for
conferences on an annual basis
and the idea is to have a
global kind of network that promotes
a discussion for for best practices
new approaches and emerging technologies
for
data management processing analytics and
visualization
recently the most of the most of the
[Music]
talks we have
are related to topics about
deep learning and computer vision and
nlp
but actually there are a lot of
variations of the of the talks
and the meetup is
is driven by volunteers so there is no
profit
it's just a bunch of volunteers running
around trying to arrange them
the high data is a chapter organized by
the project organized by amphobos a u.s
company
that mainly sponsors the topic of the
the continued development of open source
tools
some of the projects you can see on the
screen
should there be pandas maybe matplotlib
they are the
projects that are sponsored by pineapple
focus and
yes heidel cyprus is one of those global
chapters
it's based in limassol
there is no other one in cyprus the only
one for now
and
we are almost 800 members so we are we
are one of the
largest meetup meetups on the on the
island
and we
try to keep it active and to do meetups
on a monthly basis
during coffee it was not the it was not
the easiest thing
but on the other hand it was
we could manage to bring some some
speakers abroad
if you want to say hi you can find us
here on twitter in meetup and youtube
at the moment the organizer is
it's me chris
and
and nick
and that's
all from me
if you have any questions about um
okay
[Music]
so that
it's easier to press here
okay
uh so welcome
uh both to those who are here and those
who are online we are very excited to
host this event at the office of fema so
the first
in person event that we have been in
some time now
sam georgina and they had the pi here in
quicktech and i will
talk to you about automated machine
learning and the way that we approach
this topic and
we do that in order to offer
an easy way for customers to go from
data acquisition to modern predictions
only with a few clicks
before um
let's see
so before going into the details of
photo ml uh i i think it's relevant to
give you an overview of the company so
that you can better understand also the
problem we're trying to solve and why
what we do is a good solution to it we
hope
so
here in deepak tech our mission is to
revolutionize the way that the companies
store transform and use their data to
increase the rest sentence so
most of the companies nowadays already
are aware of the value of data that they
have and they know that using this data
they could
uh
gain some valuable insights about their
customers about their business but we're
still far away from actually being able
to store all this amount of data
transform it properly and then use it
somehow to draw meaningful insights and
data driven decisions
so we offer to these companies that uh
have common
communication with customers some tools
to
for example crm telephony platform
payment gateway and
we facilitate them to collect transform
and analyze the data and on top of that
we offer a set of ai solutions
uh with uh often
enhanced with explanation and insights
from this
explanation
and
in general we try to
produce to to
drive our solutions with ai
but what does this mean in morning day
so let's
look at the same problem from from the
side of our customers the companies that
need to face customer customers and
enhance their experience
so what we normally have here this is
the customer journey for a customer who
wants to do business with a company that
is normally online
uh so we start with some strangers here
some people who haven't heard of this
company and they start receiving some
materials so marketing either from
online channels and some social
social media and
advertisements some advertisements
normally as we know them in traditional
and all this material will drive them to
become visitors to the company's website
so at this point we have already a big
set of marketing data that has been uh
produced during this process and we and
the company has been able to attract
some visitors on the next step
these visitors are asked to fill in some
forms possibly
perform some actions in order to become
to gain access to the company's
website and become what we call leads so
prospective customers people who may or
may not pay some money to the to the
company at this point we we already
gathered more data about the prospective
customers we have profile data some
emails some information that they were
willing to provide
uh so at this point we have leads we are
in the middle of this specific class on
the journey now you cannot
okay
so we are here and then
the company starts actually trying to
convert those people and make them spend
money or theirs on their services or
products so here we have possibly a call
center agents calling the prospective
customers we have
other sales communications emails
exchange etc and we
start
increasing our data enhancing
what we have so far with additional
sales data
and even when the
lead becomes paid customer and
one could say that okay the journey ends
here we keep collecting data all the
transactions that take place between the
customer and the company uh maybe the
way that they
uh they communicate with the company
always stored and
we start enhancing the customer data so
it's evident i supposed all of us that's
using
behind the scenes like okay i will just
say
using all these data that
the company has collected we can
actually train different types of
machine learning assist models for
example we can
automatically score market marketing
campaigns and try to understand which
are the best ones for the type of
clients that we want to track we can use
profile data sales data possibly
enhanced with marketing data to
perform automatic lead scoring and try
to figure out who are the most valuable
uh prospective customers for our company
then sales data can also be used for
predicting the lifetime
value of
specifically
and even when elite has become a
customer we are interested to figure out
uh who among our customers are probable
to churn so stop doing business with the
company so that we can possibly contact
them with some offers etc so there is a
lot of room for machine learning
operations here and
trade model training here and what is
normally the situation nowadays is
described here so it's the manual
machine learning training pipeline that
we
i suppose most of us are more or less
familiar with
so what we have is a manual process we
need a data scientist to actually grab
some data
and start performing data cleaning
and pre-processing
algorithms so that
they can
add some structure to the data and later
transform this data into a set of
features
select which are the most
the better the best among these features
and use them to
for analysis to start under
the data so that the data scientist is
able to select a model to train and once
all this process and a couple of months
has passed the data scientist is able to
start training the model then once this
is done the
the process is still not finished since
you can use some unseen data some
specific data to tune the model and try
to optimize it for your customers needs
this is um the positive i see in this
process is that you you you do use and
hopefully benefit from the expertise of
the data scientists so data scientists
are used into looking at data
they
from
experience only they can understand some
some indicate they see some indications
and can assume what is the best model to
train how to train uh get the feeling
about the initial parameters etc however
it's not a scalable solution once you
train one model you serve one customer
that's all you can do nothing about it
for the next case
it's a time consuming as i said you can
expect that this whole process will take
anything from one month for a for a
problem that you have already solved and
that you are experienced as a data
scientist up to three or four months for
more difficult and ansi problems
and of course this cannot be delivered
with a cicd pipeline you cannot expect
that the model
will be updated or
continuously delivered to the customer
uh and
the the
manual process actually
goes
further than the actual training process
so here this
this block in the center is uh comprises
from the steps that we saw before i have
also added the evaluation and validation
of the model so once this process ends
you have a trained model and this is put
into a registry manually and then there
is a different service that will go pick
up this model and serve it to the
private service service to the
prediction service so you can see that
there is a complete
separation between all the machine
learning operations and the actual uh
company operations where the model is
served to this prediction service
everything is offline it's driven by
scripts uh the release operations for
the models are very infrequent because
you have to wait for the whole process
that we saw earlier to complete before
releasing a new model
and then
even though even if you manage to reduce
the deployment circle this only will
refer to the prediction service you can
redeploy the service that is
that is predicting you cannot do
anything about the training process
and
some is another
important i think drawback of this
approach is that we don't we have no
active performance monitoring we can uh
integrate into the prediction service
some tools to actually monitor how the
system is doing how the model is
doing with the predictions with the task
that it needs to solve but you cannot
actively monitor it so if something goes
wrong there is nothing you can do about
it you can just ask the data scientist
to investigate it and wait three months
for the circle to complete
so what we are looking into is this
instead of the previous architecture so
we start here with a data monitoring
service this only purpose is to look
into the
um into the historical data that some
data source is producing and when this
service thinks that we have enough data
triggered an automated pipeline so the
previous manual process has been
replaced by this pipeline that we see
here and we will discuss further in the
following uh slides how this is built
but we can expect that at the end we
have a trend model
at the output and stored into the modern
storage here
we also communicate with them serving
the model serving
module here and this is responsible to
serve the newly created model to the
prediction service
after the prediction service produces
some predictions it cannot give them to
the performance monitoring service and
again this will actively
monitor the system meaning that if this
service thinks we have an error it can
trigger a new um
it can trigger again the training
pipeline and improve the results
uh in an automated way
uh what it is important to say here is
that the only input to the automatic
automl pipeline apart from the training
date of course we need to train machine
learning so historical data is this um
metadata that we store in some external
um
storage and
is enough to describe the the task that
we need to solve so the type of model
and the way that we want to solve the
specific tasks
so i will now start going into more
details about the admin library
so to address this
central block here
uh we have built the autumnal library
this is a set of tools that
start
processing raw data and
as these are produced by any data source
and
in two steps that reprocessing part and
the modeling part they can produce at
the end
at the other end
in a fully automated way a machine
learning model that solves a task as
this is described in some configurations
so what we need as an external
application in order to be able to use
the optimal library is to have some raw
data
understand what type of task what type
of problem we need to solve and we will
see this later because this may
sound
complicated but it's not it's just like
okay take this data and do some
classification in order to detect this
column it's a very simple way of
configuring the problem and then
what
the library does is first it fits the
selected pipeline so it performs
training and on top of that it is able
to transform the raw data
using the fitted pipeline so perform
inference this means that the prediction
service that we saw earlier will not uh
have to
implement the inference code from there
from its side but it is enough to import
this library and
actually transform the data using the
fitted pipeline that is so stored of
course into a model
registry so
there is a separation in the
pre-processing pipeline in the modeling
pipeline and this is only because we are
interested to
implement different optimization methods
otherwise it is all um can be all it can
all be considered as a single pipeline
um and yeah we haven't found any use
cases where you need only pre-processing
or only modeling but this could also be
supported if needed
so um let's see first some information
more information about the processing
pipeline uh so as we see here this is
um comprised by a set of different
modules where we
start by raw data and the first one that
we normally apply is the initial step of
course this is a pipeline so you can
choose to meet some of these components
if you think this is better for your
modeling but the default approach is to
go through all these steps so we start
with some
initial pre-processing simple things
like a rule-based
column removal if you know that your
data has some known bias this is where
you can easily remove it some with some
pattern
recognition on the names of the columns
just with uh there are several ways to
fill the data at this point
uh then we have some statistical data
imputation
and then we start handling
each column according to their data type
so the first 100 that we have support
here is the date time
handler
we normally just transform date times
from
the
usual format to difference from a base
time this is better for machine learning
processing later
uh we transform booleans into
categorical features we
at this point we are able to understand
booleans in any way that these are
marked in zero ones or through false or
any other way that
they show the same their millions
and then
the output of booleans and the other
remaining categorical columns will go to
the categorical handler
this is where we apply one hot encoding
and some dimensionality reduction and
this is the first handler that supports
a local tuning so we use
at this point
specific metric explained variance uh
the variance that can be explained for
for the remaining from the remaining
columns in order to optimize and tune
this specific um
module then we go to the text handler
here we we handle all three texts so we
do some
simple nlp steps we apply sentence we we
take we calculate sentence and bendings
using birth networks and then we apply
some dimensionality reduction based on
umap again we have support local
optimization based on trustworthiness
this is another metric that has been
designed for
evaluating
eu map dimensional reduction and the
reason why we here we use we choose to
use uh local optimizations is that these
are very specific pre-processing steps
that are not based that you cannot
optimize them based on the final
evaluation metric as you would do for
the global optimization so we we see
that this is a better architecture
and then once we go through all the
handlers
we go to the final step where we
standardize all the features that we
have created using the standard scaler
and we impute the newly created volumes
as we did in the initial step for the
existing columns so
it's um i think relevant to know that
it's very easy to implement a new
handler you can actually pick up any any
handler from sklen or implement your own
and it's very easy to integrate this
into the preprocessing pipeline and add
it for your data if you think that
something is missing from here
and once we
complete once the preprocessing pipeline
is completed
we go to the modeling pipeline
this is an abstract term that describes
different types of machine learning
pipelines we so far we support
classification and clustering pipelines
we are looking into other approaches as
well but
we haven't really identified
a use case that can be
better served by another algorithm so
for now we have these two
and just for your understanding we can
look a bit closer into the
classification pipeline here so once we
have the features
all the features that have been
generated by the processing pipeline the
first thing to do is
i think
yeah okay the first thing to do is to
select the features that are more
relevant to them
a problem
[Music]
sorry i think i have to change
my slides because this is an older
version
sorry just give me one second
can we get questions can you get
questions now or at the end yeah super
fair it's fine with me
if you you want to ask anything just
just a mutant
and that's
yeah i'm ready to
okay
no i cannot find the actual the newest
version but i remember i had to change
this because this is the school based
from the previous slide so the feature
selection of course does not standardize
features and doesn't include the columns
what it does it
applies different ways to select
features for example i remember now that
we have
recently implemented the feature
selection based on shop this is a
metric that
figures out the
importance of
the explanation power of certain
features so once we select the features
that we want to include in our modeling
we continue with dimensionality
reduction for example pca we have uh
encoder we have um again to
reduce the nationality of the data at
this point and then of course we proceed
with the tuning of the classifier
uh we have different classifiers
implemented for example
random forest logistic regression
okay i think these are those that are
implemented at this point and
the same as in all other steps this can
also be
optimized in a global way so we can
train
all of these classifiers and then
select the one that is better
for our problem
and to
uh yeah understand a bit better the
global optimization what we do is that
we use the final evaluation criteria
and we just um iterate over the whole
pipeline the whole modeling pipeline
in order to
figure out the best parameters uh as as
a set as a total not just the best
parameters for the feature selection and
then the best parameters for the next
step and um
we can manage the
time that we need to
optimize our model by setting a maximum
let's say
trials that we are willing to go through
in order to optimize as this is a
process that can take forever
this is an example of um
of a configuration file as i said
earlier although we we have a lot of
parameters in the automl and one could
specify specific values for most of the
parameters
we don't expect the user or the
application who is using the ottoman
library to know the parameters to use
the idea is that they don't need to
specify anything they just give you the
training data
uh here on the top of them
here at the top of the configuration
file for example you just specify the
column of your data that
is the target the label that you want to
use for training this is all of course
supervised learning
the type of the target and then some i
don't know what this is doing really but
i suppose something about the
the values that are none then needs to
be included
anyway and then some parameters about
the
actual
model to use the type of model to use
classification if you want to specify
usex boost that's fine if you don't
specify it the other ml will just
try to figure out what is the best and
then some some configurations about
optimization so which optimizer to use
and with how many trials you're willing
to go through
and so this
summarizes the architecture and the
features of the offer that are offered
by the admin library and
what i would like to
point out here is that
it can get tricky to actually
monitor the experiments that you're
running so the mail
works in a way that tries too many
things in a in a two compact way
and we think that a very important step
that we do in order to actually be able
to use it to mail and understand how
everything is modeled is the integration
with ml flower flow is an open source
platform that is built to manage uh
end-to-end machine learning life cycle
it offers four different packages to
track the experiments to
um version models to actually register
models and then to track whole projects
we are only offering full integration
with
the ml flow tracking
package
and this is so that we can
create fully reproducible experiments
when you have
an experiment in automl with a few
hundred
optimization steps uh you want to be
able to understand how you got there
cross-check that everything is um that
everything is selected in the best way
possible and of course for us as data
scientists it is the only way to be able
to understand what parts are missing
from automatic
so that we can start the implementation
of those and compare between different
dance to better understand the
data
that we have in the way that we model
uh anything so um
i will just show you a short
um
ml flow integration and this is not to
show you the tool and animal flow this
[Music]
[Music]
and
we have
some
several optimization operations we can
see from the names of the runs that here
we are killing the model training
here with some view map per step
and so on and then here at the top we
get the best winning configuration
so
we start by looking into the parameters
of the
of the
parameters of the
whole setup the model what are the
and then we have a whole bunch of
metrics that we have implemented in the
mail for a classification problem so any
problem that you asked so as
classification you will have this type
of
parameters
and then on top of that you keep a whole
bunch of artifacts for example
we have here some confusion matrix that
is automatically
produced
and we have
the reported association report
et cetera so a lot of information that
we can
use to track the experiment understand
what might have gone wrong
and
yeah
if you have more than one experiments
more than one configurations we can
actually comparatively compare those
is that
it also acts as
okay okay it also acts as a first
version of the metadata storage that we
saw earlier so we know that a winning
configuration can be stored in a in a
compact way as a just a set of
configurations
and it could be used for
automation so that we directly go into
the ml
into the ml flow output pick up the best
configuration of an experiment and
repeat training for our new training
data
okay
okay okay
so let's see some actual results that we
have been able to
receive using watermel uh i started with
a very
well-known data set that i think we all
did in our i don't know university
courses
uh we tried machine learning on that
this is the titanic data set from cargo
so we have information for passengers
that were on the titanic and we want to
figure out if they survived the incident
or not
and
the benchmark accuracy on this data on
kaggle is around 85
and we can see here that just feeding
this data on
automatic we can get a similar
accuracy so this is not very interesting
of course since we all know that this is
a very well
researched data set and no one would
like to use a domain for it
so
let's see how we're doing some real
problems from our customers so a common
problem is the intelligent lead scoring
this is where as we said earlier we use
lead data lead profile data and we want
to train a model that will given a score
saying how possible is that this
lead will convert into a paying customer
and
once a salesperson has the score is
helping them decide whether to actually
spend their resources and call this
leave or not so for this type of
[Music]
problems we still we also have data
catalysts available
in this data set we have a benchmark
accuracy of 91 and we thought a male
even a very old version of the man we
managed to achieve 93 accuracy which is
very um
i mean it's very
good result but
to be honest for for a real use case of
the customer who wants to use lead
scoring it doesn't mean anything what we
think is very interesting to see
is a
actual case study with one of our
customers
we have
um
we have
a data set with
one
100 000 leads
and
among them we have three to four percent
conversion rate
um using our automl um
we were able to very successfully uh
order these leads
in terms of how possible probably is
that they will convert and what we see
here is an actual way to um explain this
from a business point of view so what we
have is a graphics
graphic with the top and percent of
leads on the horizontal axis and then
the cumulative conversion ratio on the
on the other axis what this
tells us is that
although you have three to four percent
conversion ratio if you look at one half
the first
100 uh leads in a random way when you
order them based on our lead scoring and
you look into the in the into the five
percent of your data you can ensure that
you we can ensure that you that you have
67 percent of the whole conversions and
if you go to the
20 of the whole data you can expect that
you have 99.
7 of the conversions so what this means
for our customers is that you can free
the time of your agents they can handle
more leads and of course they can
increase the conversion rates for your
company
the next use case that we have here
is
the intelligent trend prediction and
in this case we have customers that are
already paying for your service or your
product and we want to understand how
probably it is that they will stop doing
business with you so again we provide a
probability and this what this says to
this to the agent is that you need to
pay more attention to this guy or okay
this guy is safe he will not turn
again sorry but i have a good version of
the slides
um
and
yeah
okay let's focus on the table first so
we have uh the term prediction use case
i will tell you the numbers because
they're not on the slide we have uh from
the same um
customer that we saw before uh we kept
the converted customers this is around
6200
customers and we know that from them
among them 6.5 is expected to change
within the next three months we try to
and to
figure out which are the most
um possible to churn and when we look at
this as a classification task we managed
to get to around 70 percent of um
accuracy uh this is uh
that i was considering to
include in the beginning but i decided
that it's not very meaningful it just
gives us the
true positive versus for support to play
and of course
from my
classification
from a default evaluation of
classification we know that the bigger
this area is the best
your classifier is doing
okay so i suppose that
um
okay so this is
the same information we just discussed
and
these are the use cases and
the
topics that i want to discuss for this
talk
so to conclude
we think that we have a nice
set of tools already existing in our
company to automate
the creation of
machine learning models and the delivery
of these models for customers
right now we're very interested and we
are actively looking into adding
explanation and all these models that
we're building we already have some
support of explanation in other ml but
we're looking into
enhancing it and improving it
and
yeah that's all for me so
i'm happy to take questions
thank you very much georgina
uh
also it was a very nice it's very nice
presentation i i really like customer
tools thank you
there are a lot of them around right yes
yes of course and uh
it seems to me that it's this one is
kind of uh
it has its focus right on on the
customer kind of on on getting more
customers into the journey right yes
[Music]
i would start with the questions but i
want to first ask the audience if they
have any questions please
from the
audience here the audience virtually
if you have questions just i'm news
otherwise i have a lot of
i can repeat the question could we use
this methodology in combination with nlp
to automate a repository to sort
articles proceeding ctc
and fork other repositories for a
research community
and at the end apologies my question is
naive not an ml expert
i'm trying to
get the question also here too
there
okay so
as i mentioned first of all we do
support the
handling of energy
nlp handling of text at this point we
don't have a specific task that we want
to solve we just want to
transform
free text into a data type that is more
suitable for machine learning tasks such
as
classification or clustering however
it is
easy not easy to implement but easy to
add it as a functionality in automatic
uh hardware that we specifically solve
this problem so
um so that because i suppose this means
cluster articles i i suppose i'm not
sure so we could uh
implement the handler to cluster
articles based on any algorithm that we
want
the way that we do it in impact tech we
have another library it's called ai
common we implement all the
algorithms the machine learning
algorithms that we want there we made up
an existing sklen
tool if we think that this is the best
way to do it and then we just pick it up
from the ai common and we create a
handler that can be
uh used into the ottoman pipeline so i
don't know if this is
this source
uh yes thank you very much yeah actually
yeah i posed the question yeah i'm just
trying to see if we can use this other
tool to avoid the use of a curator for
the article so we can we could track
citations
facilitate the repository in order to
function automatically and and save us
the trouble of having to manually uh
sort through so yeah thank you very much
for the for the answer
and for the presentation thank you very
much thank you
any more questions
um hi i have a question
how is it is to integrate some new every
now and then we see for example pytorch
tensorflow coming with new models how
easy it is to integrate the model
in automl
and that is not out of the box it's not
it's not a standard model
you might need a bit of understanding of
what's going on or with graph neural
networks for example
that it's
it's not the typical conventional
machine learning
models
there i guess there is
some work need to be done to
incorporate these
new models
uh yes thank you for the question
of course if you want to integrate a new
model or a new algorithm you have to be
able to use it
yourself so the way that we do it is
that we we start them
we start with data scientists who
understand the specific problem solve it
offline in a python notebook with all
the normal tools that data scientists
would use and then we try to figure out
how to automate this process and then
comes integration into the mail so
no the user if what you ask is if the
user can
start using a
model that is already not integrated in
automatic this is not possible it has to
start from us
but uh once you know how to use the
model and you understand the way that we
that the automl is structured uh as a
pipeline with fit and transform
paradigms then i think that it does not
require a lot of uh skills you just go
there and write the function that
actually
fits and transforms your data
okay thank you for your presentation and
for the question it's
it doesn't still have some years left to
work on
so autumnal will not replace them yet
thank you very much
it's not it's not our purpose to replace
that aside because i'm a data scientist
so i would hate if i lose my job
and i i think that most of data
scientists would agree with me it's very
fun and it's nice and games when you
first need to solve a problem
but when you you just need to keep
retraining with new data and then
changing one parameter and then
repeating repeating repeating and then
saying to the customer why this doesn't
work because come on
it's not supposed to work
so it gets at this point it gets tiring
and you lose the excitement so this is
the process that we want to
replace and not the original work of
data scientists
okay that's clear thank you thank you
very much again
thank you
and i saw
in one slide that
and before training your model uh
you may be doing a
[Music]
dimensional reduction or standardize
your data before
training around your model
um is there any chance and
despite of
gaining
more performance scores and better
performance scores
you may lose
[Music]
in some way and interpretability into
your results
and
[Music]
yeah yeah
so
we
applied dimensionality reductions in
different stages of the pipeline
and the
the reason that we do that is so that we
can ensure we are not just throwing away
data that can be used later
in the first stages the pre-processing
stages when we apply the emotional
reduction this is based on
simple statistics like how often do you
see nuns in this volume and we know very
well from data science that if you have
a column with 95
max it will not
offer any real
[Music]
prediction power to your data so you can
throw it away if it is so often not
these are the columns that we throw away
in the beginning then as we go further
into the process we can
utilize
the actual output of machine learning
training to understand whether some
features are useful or not so the
dimensionality reduction that we perform
inside the model training pipeline and
you can ensure from the way that the
outcomes work that you are not throwing
away any data that is useful to the
modern training okay
for the
processing you are using part right
could you modify it or
add another deep learning model such as
gt3 in order to come up with more
features
for example sentiment analysis for some
projects yes we as i said we can we use
another library that is also
created in in our company a common
library where we
implement different
different algorithms we have the
sentiment analysis
model in fact
and we also support different ways to
train
to train models for the same tasks so we
have for sentiment analysis we have a
model that is based on text we have
another one that is based on text class
audio since we also have a lot of
telephony data
and the way that um
so in this library you can go and just
create any training script to to train
your model you can distribute if you
want
to although i in our data and our
specific
use cases i don't see that this need we
haven't seen this need this may change
so you you implement there everything
you would implement for the training
your model and then just go from
automatic and link to this
this training space so that you can
incorporate them into your pipeline
first question was about how
do you use
[Music]
so as i said
we
we offer the predictions of the service
so
the service that is
the that is that the customer is using
uh
we use the automl prediction the
transformation
functions to actually serve the model to
the customer
but not the training
yeah you don't you don't plan to offer
it as a sauce or for other companies to
use
we have i mean
we have uh discussed this in the past
and there are some issues with uh data
chains no
if they have to
if they want to use it and from their
side
they would normally not like to give us
data and
i mean
this runs on our cloud yeah that would
mean being run and managed by them again
i guess yeah
you can ask there about the
next goals and eight days series in our
roadmap but
if you ask me this will have more
problems than
it will generate more problems that it
will solve
more questions because i have a lot
yeah
i was i was wondering about the input is
is actually the output of the
pre-processing pipeline so we
receive raw data
we at this point we expect that there
are no nested
areas inside the data but
we have automated tools to flatten the
data as well so any type of data
um
can be
fed into a
step that i haven't shown here it's a
way to just flatten the data and then
feed it to the other
and raw data and then at the end of the
preprocessing pipeline you have a
tabular data ready to
i
okay text what do you mean for sentiment
analysis yeah i mean yes you can do it
you can give like text
plus your target yes and if your problem
is solved with classification or
clustering it's fine
at the first steps of the of the data
input
to sort out okay what's what's the data
and then it makes the
needed to be able to keep them in there
i mean you cannot give audio
like mp3 files and expect to do
something it has to be json file or usb
file
anything that can be described there but
you can if it is text and you want to do
sentiment analysis as let's say as test
text classification or any text
classification not only sentiment
analysis you can say okay this is my
text in one column
or in one frame of mutation object then
give the label in the second field and
then if your problem is solved with the
with the
the models that are implemented so
with
regression and extra boost i'm not sure
how well
and
this
possible but
they could work because as we said
particularly for text we do birth we do
new maps so we do some fancy processing
and you can expect it to work for this
case so for text classification yes
foreign tasks like um
entity recognition
i wouldn't expect to
work although you can still try to
moderate those classifications so say
okay this is my class
the entity person the entity
organization and
try to see what happens it's an
interesting question in fact i will try
it okay and is it similar with image
data i mean
no i don't think
in our
data in our use cases but if we see it
it's a matter of again implementing the
the way to handle these images
maybe i don't know dumbbell mass
pixels i don't know i haven't worked
with
[Music]
i think i think we can i mean if there
are no more questions we can at least
stop the online session and we can have
a
chat at least the people that are here
and so think again georgina
and thank you everybody for for being
with us and everybody here that are
physically here
and we'll see you around in the next
meetup hopefully
bye-bye
hi everyone thank you very much
[Music]